l'espagne frappée de plein fouet par la
pandémie
ce samedi le ministère de la santé a
enregistré une hausse des décès de 32%
en 24 heures pour un bilan total de 1300
26 décès de plus 24 milles 926 personnes
infectées par le coc u19 ont été
recensés par les autorités soit 16 5% de
plus que vendredi
l'espagne est le deuxième foyer de
l'épidémie en europe derrière l'italie
vendredi déjà la barre symbolique des
1000 morts avait été franchie mais
malheureusement nous devons encore
compter les décès il est humide de décès
à ce jour dans certaines communautés
autonomes le nombre total de cas et en
os le pourcentage de décès peut encore
diminué la vérité est que parmi les
patients graves appartenant à des
groupes à risque il y aura évidemment un
taux de mortalité plus élevé que parmi
les autres biens 21 athènes et l'on a on
attache est allé à choper un instant
samedi 14 mars
le chef du gouvernement pedro sanchez a
instauré l'état d' alerte pour une
période de 15 jours dans tout le pays
conséquence la population est invitée à
rester confinés sauf cas d'extrême
nécessité
seuls les supermarchés kiosque et
pharmacie restent en activité
tout comme les transports les parcs et
lieux publics
honteux fermer leurs portes quant à
l'armée elle a été déployée dans les
villes pour désinfecter des lieux
publics et veiller au respect des
mesures de confinement
la déclaration de l'état d'urgence
touche l'ensemble du territoire espagnol
pour une durée de quinze jours qui peut
être prolongée avec l'autorisation du
congrès et des députés si nécessaire à
tout moment et lorsque cela sera
nécessaire pour l'attacher l'exécution
efficace des mesures nous disposerons de
l'action des forces armées l'armée est
déjà préparée à cela il ya juste après
par appareil le gouvernement espagnol a
aussi dû faire face à la question des
sans abri dans la capitale
la municipalité a accepté que la feria
de madrid accueille 150 sd
2 présentant aucun symptôme à barcelone
c'est le parc des expositions de la fira
qui aménage un de ces pavillons pour
ouvrir ses portes à 1000 personnes sans
domicile
la décision qui devrait améliorer pour
un temps le quotidien des personnes dont
la vie c'est un peu plus compliqué
depuis le début de la pandémie
cela est horrible nous ne voyons
personnel dans les rues nos urines ont
ou nous pouvons parce qu'en plus de cela
la police et sur notre dos les agents
nous disent de rentrer chez nous mais
nous n'avons pas de domicile
c'est tout ce que nous pouvons faire
nous allons devoir rester dans la rue de
leur côté les professionnels de santé
déplorant un manque de moyens alors
qu'une personne sur dix est en
réanimation
le ministre espagnol de la santé
salvador ya annoncé que 300 mille
masques devrait arriver très
prochainement
bien que le ministre de la santé a
prévenu que les pires jours reste à
venir
une bonne nouvelle est tout de même à
noter 2125 patient espagnol sont
désormais considérés comme guéris